[Applause]
it's interesting um man with the special
stuff going on right now i didn't want
to say it because i didn't want to put
anything out there when it first
happened but when when chappelle dropped
the special and
and uh netflix didn't back down and
shouts to netflix for not backing down
yeah much respect much respect but uh
everybody was like i think um
i think even uh one of the
damon wayne's even said like chappelle
freed the slaves like they were going
thank god a black guy said something
like that
like bob saget just comes out
chapelle did it he freed us but you
can't even really support it because you
can't as a not black person be like
that's what i've been trying to say
they'd be like what
so i
the initial reaction was like that's it
comedy's different now we can say
whatever we want now i didn't want to
say anything because i didn't want
to put it out there in the world you
know but
the second i saw this much backlash
for
chappelle
yeah i'm like
yeah
this is the worst possible thing for
comedy because if
he's getting that backlash
if you're a young comic yeah you have no
chance
to be edgy they're not taken if they're
worried like if they're having to make
if the head of the company is having to
make statements on behalf of
the most popular comic
arguably in history
right
it's jokes yeah if he has to make
statements
and potentially apologize for some of
the things that he said or not being
able to understand he came back and i
thought he handled it really well but
apologize for not really understanding
like what the trans community is his
workplace he said he's not hate speech
definition exactly no he he was great i
think how he's handled is mashful but
the fact that he's got to make these
comments we don't hear him commenting on
anything else yeah right they're not
asking him to comment on bridgerton
they're asking a comment on any of these
other things so it's like that's going
around internally and that's causing a
lot of fuss internally yeah so if he's
got to come out and he's got to address
what's going on he's going hold on i'll
do this for chappelle i ain't doing this
for john flanagan or the random young
comic that's trying to come up doing a
15 minute special yeah so
it's too much [ __ ] heartache it's too
much stress yeah it's too much pressure
on the network yeah so
we can go and we can look at this and be
like this is amazing that we got to see
it
but the commotion isn't gonna affect
chappelle it's gonna affect the new
comics trying to be edgy yeah i it's not
worth the risk so you're i the whole
time i've been on the side of this is
the tipping point because the silent
majority felt confident saying openly yo
guys this is funny who cares i think
uh mistake we also and netflix didn't
back down but i think a mistake i might
have made i hope i didn't but you sound
right right now is uh i thought it's
kind of like court where the precedent
has been set and now we all are going to
follow this precedent every case that
comes up where somebody's offensive
netflix was like well we didn't take
down chappelle but that's a good way of
thinking also is uh nobody i already had
to deal with this for chappelle i'm not
dealing with it for you it's it's the
jordan rules
oh yeah
the refs
protect jordan yeah right you went to
the rim heart
a foul is gonna get called right
maybe if it's a light foul if it's
jordan you're gonna call it yeah if
you're bullying him you're gonna call it
there's issues yeah right that the refs
are gonna have and maybe the league was
telling the refs yo you gotta look out
it's superstar treatment exactly it's
gretzky yeah right we gotta make sure
gretzky is the league this is the brand
quarterbacks in the nfl
you can't hit them too low you can't hit
them too high
quarterbacks [ __ ] yeah you know what i
pick up they're
mean you gotta go through that rookie
treatment my fear my concern is
and this is what happened before
this was what the climate was before uh
i put out uh 441 and then views for the
views from the assist the climate was
like there was a lot of comics
that
were changing what they wrote jokes
about and how they wrote jokes because
they're like there's no way i can get on
netflix or there's no way that i can get
on hbo or showtime if i am this edgy
because that's not what they're putting
out right yeah so
my fear is that happens again in the
same way that people have changed what
they post on instagram they change what
they post on tick tock we change what we
post on tik tok we take all the curse
words out we just blank the curse words
because if you post it with the curse
words they take it down right
account gets banned whatever that
changes how you write jokes yeah that
changes
how comedy
is digested yeah and it changes how you
think creatively you go do i want to
work six months on a joke that i know
can't go anywhere or on any platform
yeah you start going
i'm not saying it's something that i've
done but there are people that
completely understand them who start
going look i got to make this special
this is how i make a living i make
specials and if i have a trans joke and
that's going to get cut when i go to
netflix because i'm not as big as dave
chappelle
i'm not going to do the transfer right
that's what people are going to think
yeah and
i yeah i i didn't want to [ __ ] say it
because i was hoping that the backlash
would just kind of go away and i think
within a month this thing will be gone
but
i don't think that this is a great
moment for comedy and this is the
tipping point and now we've moved past
it i i think that
if you try to do a trans joke on any
major network right now the note will
come in hey we don't want to deal with
it
i hope
that
if people support netflix very publicly
yeah the majority of people are open and
say yo i'm glad netflix didn't take this
down i'm glad netflix didn't back down
then maybe netflix will be kind of like
all right you know what we took some
heat from these people but the majority
support what we did it's on the majority
to keep being vocal and being like yo
these are jokes yeah funny is funny the
thing that that i agree with they
probably won't though because people
don't normally you got to be really
moved to tweet some [ __ ] yes and you're
not really going to be moved if you're
not trans if you're trans i understand
why you're moved to speak offended or
not yeah if you're not you're like yeah
i like it yeah it's also a weird thing
to support because you start
seeming like
it's positioned as hate speech and then
you're supporting it
so now you're supporting hate speech
you're not you're just supporting jokes
and jokes about everybody but if the
position that you're taking yeah
is labeled as hate speech yes now you
feel like you're the person that is
supporting the hate speech and you start
going do i really want to be the person
who says that publicly yeah i'm not a
comedian i'm not invested in this at all
is this the thing that i want to go out
on a limb to support defend yeah you
start going ah it's not worth the tweet
how often have you thrown some [ __ ] in
drafts you're like do i really give a
[ __ ] yeah all right guys we're gonna
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip because i gotta make sure your
dicks are sturdy hard dirty full to the
max and the way that we're going to do
that is with blue chew okay same active
ingredient that's inside cialis or
viagra but this is the chew this is the
one we rock with and this is the one
that we make sure the women in our lives
are satisfied with and ladies if you're
watching right now you deserve it too so
get your man on the chew the way you do
that right now you get it for free you
just gotta go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code andrew use that promo code
andrew at bluetooth.com you're gonna get
it for free all you gotta do is pay five
dollar shipping free dick and the best
dick that you've ever had in your life
fellas deliver it ladies get it
delivered you all deserve it now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
you can watch the full episode and
support the [ __ ] army at patreon.com
like the other day i posted some [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] cara delevingne girl
yeah and then
just you know she's pegged the
patriarchy or whatever like that and i
just i just posted how like super that
is with the models we talked about in a
regular episode and then instagram hits
me the next day they're like you've lost
the ability to uh add links
on your instagram
so i can't do like swipe ups or like add
links to shows and that's gonna go
because you posted a hateful speech
whatever this i don't give a [ __ ] about
this [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] about
models i'm gonna [ __ ] about pagan i
don't give a [ __ ] about the patriarchy
i lost the ability to make money
for something i don't give a flying [ __ ]
about yeah now i want to be able to just
say things that i don't give a [ __ ]
about yeah but now there's a cost to it
yeah right and so if i'm thinking the
next time i want to comment on some dumb
story that i'm forget about 15 minutes
later imagine what netflix is saying
yeah you think when netflix gets that
next special someone got a trans joke in
it you think they're not gonna look
gonna be like is it worth a month of
scrutiny
is it worth a month of scrutiny
hopefully
hopefully it takes a long time for it to
turn the other way but this is the very
beginning that doesn't mean you won't i
remember 2007 seeing pc [ __ ] start to be
a thing and some of it was needed
probably but it took a long time to get
the point in 2015 where comics were like
dude i don't know what jokes to make i
don't know how to make that was an eight
year nine year gap whatever it was
so hopefully this is the first and
there's still going to be a lot of
backlash but then it'll subside the kind
of like the outrage machine yeah and
it'll take a few years i just hope the
networks have like nuance and discretion
when it comes to why they think
chappelle is getting heat you know what
i mean like because chappelle's not
necessarily in terms of like the
criticism i'm seeing like and i agree
with your point that i think people will
feel the heat right now and be like yeah
we don't want to put like a trans joke
no matter what it is for the next month
but eventually it'll cool down and then
they'll get a comic that has a trans
joke in like a year and they'll say okay
did chappelle get cancelled because he
did the one they or many days joke or
did you get canceled because he said
gender is a fact you know what i mean
like is that what the criticism is
that's a good point and so it's like he
wasn't necessarily they weren't coming
at him and maybe they would have came at
him if it was just jokes but it was
because he made some declaration about
trans and in general i i hope that
you're right right i don't know if they
will use the discretion my my fear
is that
the criticism didn't have nuance either
right the criticism was always like hey
these jokes are transphobic literally
violence you're killing me and bobo
right but like if they specific if the
community specifically came out and said
hey that they they's joke was really
funny right but saying that gender is a
binary we think is transphobic and they
kind of swept it all up
that was the criticism then i think that
maybe even the network would be like
okay i could see how you guys are upset
about that right but it was just swept
up like you said it was one angry hate
ball
that was thrown at the trans community
and that's how they felt at least that's
how they interpret it so i'm like
like i i'm sure a hundred percent that
there's a con there's a special and a
comic has a joke about trans right now
sitting in netflix's office and they're
looking at going
okay yeah
what do you want we can keep this but
we'll push it back six months
because they definitely aren't gonna be
the network that has the transphobic
joke and then during the heat of it
drops a new special transphobic joke
like if theo vaughn had a trans joke in
his special
because his special just dropped yeah
you know go check out the o special by
the way um
i guarantee that there's going to be a
conversation at least do you really need
this heat right now you see what's
happening
yeah
it's just which i'm also curious from
netflix's perspective how much it's
affecting their bottom line like i
wonder if like they're dealing with
superficial fires but underneath they're
actually making what is this
algorithm called things that's what i'm
saying are they getting crazy
subscriptions like i don't think that oh
sorry interrupt i don't think it affects
their money at all i think what it is is
i don't think stand-up is necessarily a
money maker right so it's like
netflix probably survives off of their
like very popular series and
documentaries and also
uh
getting the rights to like friends and
these types of shows right that's what
makes up the majority of viewing time
specials are great and they're cool
little pops but i don't think that that
is the majority of time that people are
spent viewing netflix so they're looking
at this they're going do i want to get
this much i could just put documentaries
and [ __ ] getting killed like
if i put those out nobody gives a [ __ ] i
can spend millions of dollars when
[ __ ] getting killed that's the best
question possible
it's more probable people will cancel
that their netflix subscription over
this they'll probably resubscribe later
but more probable that happens then i'm
going to subscribe because of them
supporting chapelle and not bowing down
ain't gonna make no more money net
subscribers if anything they probably
dip which does suck you think so no no i
don't think i don't i don't think it
dips
in
who might cancel temporarily versus
people who will add because of this
special you see what i'm saying oh i
disagree i think way more people will
add
everybody who didn't have netflix and
couldn't watch the special
and heard about all the hoopla
yeah like goes i need to watch the
special but then to mark's point they
still won so they might look at that
this yeah they won yeah they in the
algorithm the people who just go off the
algorithm might say well this was
successful
yeah we handled the superficial flower
we got some heat blah blah blah so we'll
keep making these specials why not i
don't know if they want that kind of
scrutiny constantly and i don't know if
they want to deal with the internal
turmoil because there is internal
turmoil when you have
people leaking data that work for you
when you have people you know talking
about potential protests is a lot of
stress yeah and if that's not the thing
that actually makes you the money if the
document if tiger king makes you money
you're like yo make tiger king fam what
the [ __ ] we doing with this i was
actually shocked he made a second
statement sorry i was walking things
back he made another statement what two
days ago variety i was surprised i was
like you've already made your statement
to your point netflix doesn't seem like
they would do this netflix seems like
they just keep [ __ ] moving and to see
him make a statement i was like oh [ __ ]
this is this is still going yeah all i'm
saying is if you're you're a young comic
right now it's like
i'm not saying this is because this is
my path i'm saying is because this is
the only path for you if you're a young
comic and you want to do edgy jokes
you have to do it on youtube yeah it's
there's no other option for you yeah you
cannot it is not worth the risk for
these big networks hbo hulu showtime
netflix any of them it is not worth the
risk for your
following you don't have enough of a
following it's worth the risk for
chappelle
it's not worth the risk for a nobody
yeah so you have to build up your
following and get it to the point where
you are worth the risk if you want to do
edgy jokes if you don't want to do edgy
jokes now is the time yeah
i mean it really it really is like now
bro there's somebody who don't deserve a
special that's about to get one on
netflix because of the chappelle thing
yeah and they're thirsting for a trans
comedian they want one it's so bad you
can be a half a year into the game
they're like we need you all right let's
go yeah yeah let's [ __ ] do someone's
joke do a hot pocket thing we don't care
like make it work say you got a hot
pocket who cares like
let make it happen for real like if
you're trans right now pitch pitch pitch
yeah pitch pitch you're part of the
lgbtq community pitch pitch because they
need to prove every network will want it
because we're then we're not like
netflix more than netflix yeah oh
netflix
everybody would take it you get a
bidding war
but and and i know you're going oh you
might be thinking oh they're there's
doing this to uh what is the term
there's like um
uh they're using me as a shield right
like a token or something yeah
be a token token gets you on a subway
yeah get the token
and then what you do with that ride is
up to you you can do whatever you want
with it you can build yourself a
beautiful [ __ ] career out of it but
take the opportunity what up people you
just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you